[Musique]
retour en images sur la Journée
nationale des aidants qui s'est tenu le
6 octobre au grand kiosque du tampon une
manifestation consacrée à ses proches
qui ne comptent pas les heures pour
accompagner les personnes
âgées ou malades venus en nombre les
visiteurs ont pu s'informer auprès des
partenaires sur les dispositifs destinés
aux aidants familiaux tout en
s'accordant un moment de répit cette
journée le département voulu montrer que
qu'on est là qu'on est à côté des
aidants parce que c'est des personnes
qui sont consacrées à leurs aider ce
qu'on a voulu faire de cette journée
c'est que il puisse souffler respirer
c'est l'occasion pour le gipsap
qui est là avec eux qui les accompagne
on a tous les stands donc ils peuvent
voir que ils sont pas seuls
c'est le but c'est ça c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas seuls ne se sont pas isolés non
plus on a concocté effectivement pour
pour cette journée tout un programme qui
va leur permettre à la fois de trouver
des informations avec effectivement une
quarantaine de partenaires ici présents
sur ce site de la Plaine des Caps on
aura aussi un kiosque dédié au bien-être
qui sera aussi là avec une trentaine de
prestataires présents pour chouchouter
les aidants et on aura donc un stand
dédié donc aux conférences nous avons
réalisé effectivement des reportages sur
les aidants pour justement rendre
visible l'action menée par par ces
aidants et puis on a aussi prévu cet
après-midi
un concert un grand concert avec
plusieurs artistes justement pour
terminer cette journée dans la bonne
ambiance une bonne ambiance qui fait du
bien quand on connaît le quotidien d'un
aidant être aidant c'est un métier c'est
un boulot je vais dire que c'est un
boulot à plein temps c'est du 200% c'est
même plus de 100%, c'est du 200% parce
qu'on doit avoir l'oeil sur tous les
gestes les mouvements les déplacements
donc je suis venu ici c'est pour essayer
d'avoir des réponses à toutes mes
questions sur moi à toutes mes questions
en partie une grande partie j'espère en
sortir de là la tête remplie et d'aide
en plus des stands et ateliers pour
informer et sensibiliser le public des
conférences et la diffusion de
reportages sur le quotidien des familles
était au programme de cette journée et
s'acquillent un moment fort en émotion
et moi même j'étais dans un moment donné
ils sont coupés de mon papa qui avait
une longue maladie donc je sais ce que
c'est d'être aussi du mur matin et soir
et aujourd'hui je dirais aux aidants de
ils ne sont pas tout seul ce temps-là
est révolution donc qui n'hésite pas à
interpeler nos services nous avons aussi
beaucoup de familles qui sont dans le
grand ruralité et c'est important qu'on
a son armée des dispositifs à eux qu'on
arrive en tout cas à les proposer
qui prennent qui a des choses une belle
journée de convivialité et de partage
qui se termine mais l'accompagnement des
aidants lui se poursuit notamment à bord
de la caravane s'acquillent qui
continuera à sillonner les routes de
l'île
[Musique]